hi there rejects i'm greg album
salamander sally's with us today we are
going to do a try not to laugh challenge
funny cat and dog vines compilation' 20s
all film related for the real rejects so
figured why not sally has channel don't
watch it don't laugh that's not funny
oh that's not funny
oh it's gonna be bad oh you hear that
really whoa before me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
No
thank you
[Music]
whoa
they're real
he's out fighting I'll give you a treat
[Laughter]
Jesus
oh I look at you to push
[Music]
[Music]
Oh No
[Laughter]
[Music]
well that's Talent do that Catherine a
fat dog can't slip to hide so much
you know they had a giftie so mean
did you eat lipstick selling the art
wow that's yeah they're good John
oh I'm on a fence now
oh that fence straight door hmm
oh wow years doing YouTube I was afraid
that it would be too mean like some of
the pets get really hurt and this one
was pretty wild yeah I mean sometimes
it's cute when an animal hurts
themselves in like a silly way like they
freaked out over something dumb and then
or they're like sleeping and they fall
over well you know when you
intentionally scare them or kind of set
them up to hurt themselves I don't like
that that animal could be really I'm
watching them struggle so much don't
like they could like really yeah
especially what what they're struggling
with like there was one with the dog
would be like that
big heavy thing on it in the fend yeah
it's not funny but if it's like a paper
bag on their head that's like that's
hilarious we know where the line is for
physical comedy with animals you broke
before I did oh yeah no I was like screw
this I'm winded yeah cuz I have a cat my
girlfriend has a cat and I don't know if
you guys know this cats who don't know
each other
just introduce them no but another there
was one time where one of the cats got
through cuz we have a divider here at
her new place their fight was so nasty I
walked in in the middle of it
Olivia was trying to take one of the
cats away and they're like hair like
clumps of hair taken I hope she had this
bruise and like cuts like she was
bleeding on her forearm and that she had
this gnarly bruise on her arm I don't
know I mean just like oh that's like
that's a little bit whatever people saw
everyone had the same reaction I'm just
oh my god
like it looked like someone looked like
I beat her that's a different part of
her body that was the cat like when you
watch two cats fight like who don't know
each other who just had to kill one
another it's like watching two versions
of the flash go at it man not a cat
person for that reason how dare you
what doggie do you have really
yeah there's their lifestyle 813 wow
that's impressive you must have taken
good care of your honey what I didn't
know about this try not to cry challenge
of it Jesus all right subscribe to the
rejects avocation Val do you like dogs
like this video yes if you like cats and
check out Sally's channel that's the
other thing you must do that's important
for your life you have a page to the -
add a scoop to Steve because Sally read
his name it's Cooper Guba see is a very
talented graffiti artist below oh yeah
his art is insane I haven't talked to
you in a while scoops he would tell me
how he was doing like online dating and
everyone seemed like it would go well
but I ultimately wasn't Sally
they found my mistaken is single I was
like where is this going right yeah but
I don't use I'm ready to mingle
play with your Wingull Dingle sally is
interested because she wants to get her
body graffiti'd comes at a really big
sexually share what I just got
is as he ever graffiti'd someone scuba
diving No
[Music]
comment below this guy's goodbye